well the Royal cuteness continues Prince
William speaking out about the birth of
his nephew and guys he's got dad jokes I
break these clowns Walkman products to
the secret patient society it is
parenting that was William and Kate at
the launch of the King's Cup Regatta and
as you've probably heard Harry and Megan
welcomed their son on Monday I'm very
excited to announce that baby boy early
this morning a very healthy boy mother
and baby are doing incredibly well been
the most amazing experience I can ever
well the couple is yet to reveal of the
name so thank you for non its the babies
a little bit overdue so we've had a
little bit of time to think about it but
some yeah that's we do know their son
weighed in at 7 pounds and 3 ounces and
that Megan seemingly opted for a home
birth though details on the births are
being kept private for now we also know
that Prince Harry continues to be well
the best
we're both absolutely thrilled and so
grateful to all the love and support for
everybody out there I'm so incredibly
proud of my wife and as every father and
parent would ever say you know your your
baby is absolutely amazing but this
little thing is he has learned the
couple texted a photo of baby Sussex to
some of their family and that Megan's
mom has been by her side as for when we
will get to meet baby Sussex I think
we'll be seeing you guys in probably two
days time as planned
as I found me to be able to share it
with you guys and so everyone can see
the baby we literally cannot wait for
Wednesday for all the latest on the
Royals keep it locked to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krause and
I for now
you